hey everyone I'm Gal Gadot and I'm going
undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
how do you say quora
who wins a fight Gal Gadot or Chris
Hemsworth
what's with this question everyone are
asking me who would win a fight me or
Chris I will be a smart ass and I'll say
Chris and I are not gonna fight each
other we're gonna fight together against
evil
boasted I wait 67 kilo can Gal Gadot
Carry Me
maybe I don't know I might could Gal
Gadot be in UFC I mean let's let the
professionals do their thing I will sit
from the front row and cheer
posted
[Music]
next one how the heck is she alive
didn't she get sliced and diced by the
propeller blades oh my God
did you see a buddy I didn't see it
buddy did you
let's see some YouTube comments
I think she could be the next agent 007
why not
that's very nice of you to say thank you
I'm such a big fan of these genre I grew
up watching Bond and Mission and die
hard and born identity and the little
girl in me always wanted to play one and
I think that after the success of Wonder
Woman was when I realized wait a second
there's audience for this when it's
female-led there's more space for
female-led movies within the genre and
that's kind of what gave you one and I
my husband who's my partner the Boost of
confidence to go ahead and develop one
ourselves the action the twist and turns
the scope the drama I love everything
about these movies and I'm so happy that
you know that soon we can share Heart of
Stone with you dang how many languages
she can speak not many just two Hebrew
and English
Basta Twitter
[Music]
favorite memory filming with Patty I
love Patty so much she's one of my
closest friends our family are so close
we were so lucky that this movie brought
us together Patty and I if there's
something that we always do together is
laugh there's not just like one standout
favorite memory our entire relationship
I feel like we've had so many different
things that happened to us and that
we've been together and we've went it's
just we have this connection that is
very deep the bond is real and I'll do
anything with Betty she's incredible
Gal Gadot is going to be in the live
action Snow White that is correct so yes
I'm going to play the evil queen it was
the first time I had to kind of audition
uh for a project in a while they needed
to make sure I can sing because this is
a musical so for a month I was working
on the song and then I auditioned and we
filmed the song and I got the part and
it was very exciting and it was so much
to shoot because it's so different than
anything I've ever done it's so
delicious and delightful and I could
really go big and Theatrical I can't
wait for you to watch this movie my
favorite Disney movie
I'm trying to say was Winnie the Pooh
Winnie the Pooh was my go-to I know I
know it's very for little kids but it's
just so peaceful and always came me down
three please send your best working mom
hacks hi first of all if you're a mom a
working mom as well I just want to tell
you you're not alone we all have the
guilt and the frustration that we feel
from time to time when we're with the
kids we need to make sure we finish
everything at work when we're at work
we're thinking about the kids it's like
an inevitable War what helped me once I
read a book and it says you can only do
your best when you're with the kids be
present put the phone away and be with
the kids when you're at work put the
phone away be at work and do what you
need to do and love yourself it's okay
to work so you're giving your kids a
good modeling on how to fulfill
themselves and all of that so just take
it easy on you that's my biggest tip
Instagram
[Music]
hey girl I love you listen what's next
for you also what kind of music do you
like do you dance I love dancing I love
music I listen to everything lately my
go-to would be to go on Spotify if you
do Polo and pan I really like them like
they put you in a good vibe I also love
if you want to dance I also love noga
eres who we also brought for Heart of
Stone to create the theme song for the
movie and I fell in love with her work
when I listened to the end of the road
so check that out too that's a good one
for dancing
next Wikipedia
her first jobs were working at a local
Burger King as well as babysitting this
is correct and I still remember the
flavor of the delicious garlic Whopper
garlic Whopper is the alongside
with mac and cheese noodles
I'm hungry as you can see next one Godot
studied law at IDC herzelia College in
Israel that is correct
I studied law and I studied
International relationship and I wanted
to be I guess I watched too many
episodes of Ali macbill
and you know in Israel it's either you
become a doctor an engineer or a lawyer
so I went for the style
okay that's it I'm signing off the
internet
foreign